since her well senior Primary Care the
sponsors of this segment encourages
older adults to stay active I spoke with
the doctor to learn more
hey Dr Wakefield welcome back
hey Rocky great to be here good to see
you again I know you have some great
tips for our seniors with Center well
and their senior Primary Care
um let's start with staying active you
know as we age you get less active but
it's very important to stay active oh
exactly as we age staying active and
keeping our bodies moving becomes
increasingly important regular physical
activity helps prevent coronary artery
disease by reducing two key factors in
plant development circulating fats and
inflammation and every time we exercise
we know it lower helps to lower our
blood pressure our blood sugar and our
triglyceride level now is heart disease
one of those top reasons that older
people should stay active
well heart disease is the leading cause
of death in the United States so it's
certainly a big reason to stay active
but overall physical activity has many
health benefits from helping maintain a
healthy weight to improving mood
um and if you walk on say like a
treadmill at a gym or play sports at
your local health club or just walk
around the neighborhood exercise can
also help people stay socially connected
which we know is so important as we age
definitely hanging out just playing with
your kids your grandkids too what kind
of physical activity should seniors
engage in
so many exercises are good for seniors
and even a simple walk can work wonders
Center well offers free senior focused
Fitness classes with age-appropriate
movements at our on-site activity
centers which are local you know are
open to actual all local seniors we also
have professionals on hand to help you
guide through some of the moves that may
you know really fit your needs better
definitely and what are some of the
exercises you suggest seniors can do at
home if they can't make it to your
facility what what's so great is that
the best part of it is that you really
don't need to go anywhere or buy
anything to stay active many exercises
can be done at home you know using your
body weight as resistance things like
stepping in place squats arm and leg
raises lunges and more the important
thing to think about is that you you
know you can positively impact your
health anytime anywhere at no cost
definitely now before our seniors get
Super Active should they consult their
doctor first
oh absolutely It's always important to
talk to your own primary care physician
before starting any exercise program he
or she knows your state of health best
and can tell you really which kind of
exercises are appropriate you know for
your personally at in your Wellness
Journey okay and speaking of how can
they become patients with U.S Central
wealth it's easy to become a patient
here at Central well I would recommend
you visit
centerwelllasvegas.com and see all of
our Centers located conveniently
throughout the valley also you can show
up in one of our centers and receive a
personalized tour you know we are always
happy to welcome new patients looking
for Quality Care
thank you to Center well senior primary
care for sponsoring this segment they
have 11 locations across the Las Vegas
Valley all you got to do is head to
centerwell Las vegas.com for more
information we'll be right back